you know Abigail I was thinking about
what you were saying about us moving in
together it's a pretty good idea I love
you I love you too hey there I'm here it
starts a little longer don't worry about
it you know I am my father built your
company great wrestling push them out I
didn't think to do what happened I wish
you were there so you're part of it what
goes around comes around
rabe wrestling by the time you see this
I'll be coming for you what is it my
ex-partners son what you call Devils
station how bad is this place it's bad
it's a whole hole I've never seen
you can do this without you I cut your
background position though
oh yeah never seen anyone go to a fight
in a sports club before that's not funny
sureness hush what if you got a blinking
drone feed now we spot what's her way in
what are we waiting for
hey I got someone in there too where you
going
maybe late make a big impression we got
visitors
it was four come be standing by
[Music]
stay back
come on hit me for your father I'm done
with presents
[Music]
[Music]